i was always on the border of an
anaphylactic reaction
which is not pleasant
and that's hypersympathetic activation
no parasympathetic activation i couldn't
relax
at all that's an immunological response
allergic response yeah
so anyways that was what seemed now this
i don't like to talk about this much
because it's so bloody radical and you
know i don't like to propagate it but
this diet seems to have stopped all of
that i don't have psoriasis all of the
patches have gone yeah my gum disease
which is incurable i had multiple
surgeries to deal with it it's
completely gone took three years my
right eye which was quite cloudy it's
cleared up completely
[Music]
what else has changed well i lost 50
pounds and
like instantly and kept it off i should
mention that i i i too am not a deep
investigator of nutritional science i
have my skepticism towards the degree to
which it is currently as a science
because like a lot of complex systems
it's very it's full of mystery
uh and full of uh
profiteers the people that profit of
different kinds of diets but i should
say for me personally it does seem that
i feel
by far the best when i eat only meat
that's very interesting and i discovered
that
a long time ago first of all how do you
discover it uh so by
the discovery went like this i started
listening to ultra marathon runners
about
15 years ago
and they started talking about
fat
adapted running
so i first discovered that i don't have
to run super fast to enjoy running and
in fact i really enjoy running at a
slower pace
um so that was like step one it's like
oh okay if i maintain
something called
the math rule which is a pretty low
heart rate if i maintain that you can
actually get pretty fast while
maintaining a pretty slow average speed
in general anyway they fuel themselves
on low carb diets
so i got into that
on top of that i also they also fast
often so i discovered how incredible my
mind feels
when fasted you know people call it
intermittent fasting but well that's an
optimization of death eh because
you're when you fast your body
logically and obviously if you think
about it biologically is well what is
your body scavenge first well
damaged tissue
so
the the i know the literature on fasting
to some degree and it's it's very
compelling literature if you if you
starve dogs down i think it's 20 below
rats too below their optimal body weight
they live 30 percent longer
yeah
that's a lot thirty percent like it's
like thirty percent yeah yeah thirty
percent well there there is aspect to a
lot of these things that make me nervous
because
i always feel like there's no free lunch
that i'm gonna pay for it somehow but
there's a focus that i am able to attain
when i fast
especially when i eat once a day
my mind is almost like nervously focused
it's almost like an anxiety but a
positive one or one that i can channel
into just like an excitement you know i
wonder how much of that's associated
with
well imagine that
that signifies lack of food which not
that hard to imagine well maybe you
should be a lot more alert in that
situation right biologically speaking
because you're in hunting mode let's say
you know not desperate but in hunting
mode and god only knows
maybe human beings should be in hunting
mode all the time often but that we
don't know that so i wonder if it has
a stress on the system that long term
causes the system to doesn't it doesn't
look like it it it seems in case of
fasting not and then on top of that i
discovered that the thing i enjoy i just
don't enjoy eating
fat as much
so i love eating meat and when you talk
about low carb diets so i just
discovered through that process if
someone fatted me but just me
i just feel
a lot of the things that make me feel
weird about food like a little groggy or
like full or just
whatever uh
the aspects of food that i don't enjoy
they're not there with meat and i'm
still able to enjoy company and when i
eat once a day
and eat meat
at least in texas
you could still have all the merriment
oh yeah
you have dinner with friends now i don't
do the uh this you know you have a very
serious thing
that
um
there's health benefits that you are
very serious about for me i can still
drink whiskey
i'll still do the things that add a
little bit of
spice spice into the thing yeah now when
you completely remove the spice it it
does become more difficult yeah it's
more difficult socially and tammy seems
to only be able to eat lamb although she
might be able to eat non-aged beef and
uh that makes traveling complicated too
right because
well for obvious reasons it's like
really that's all you can eat
yeah well c'est la vie and maybe that's
a form of craziness but
you